it's um breaking news regarding the
figures death figures for Cove in
nineteen across the UK regionally and
believe we can speak to our reporter Ali
Fortescue who can contextualize these
for us we're still waiting of course and
from the Department of Health and Social
Care update which amalgamates the
figures in a slightly different way Ali
but tell us about the figures that we
just have yes in the last few moments
we've had some of the figures from our
nation's and it does look like the
numbers have fallen it is of course a
Sunday so worth remembering that
sometimes we see a lag over the weekend
and the numbers do come down but in
England 482 more deaths reported
yesterday that figure was 784 so that is
actually the lowest daily figure for
nearly two weeks that brings the total
in England to fourteen thousand four
hundred we also have the numbers for
Scotland ten more deaths again
significantly lower than yesterday we
must remind you that there is often a
lag on Sunday we often see these figures
falling quite low on a Sunday and then
jumping up again on Monday so worth
remembering that that brings a total in
Scotland to 903 but then in Wales the
number has gone up slightly forty-one
more deaths that is compared to
twenty-eight yesterday bringing the
total there to five hundred and seventy
five so these figures do seem to be
relatively consistent with the overall
trend we're seeing that curve flattening
the raped slowing having said that even
at a slower rate if we carry on at this
rate then we will pass 25,000 deaths
towards the end of next week and that of
course you'll remember the chief
scientific adviser saying would be a
good case scenario if we didn't pass
20,000 deaths even at a slower rate and
of course the numbers today are a little
lower even at a slower rate it does seem
like we may well pass 20,000 deaths and
we are still talking about hundreds of
deaths every single day